data store is a database that runs in
the Google cloud and is available to any
App Engine application as you already
heard it is built on BigTable which is
used by many of the huge services being
run at Google so that also gives
datastore unlimited scalability please
see the instructor comments for more
information on BigTable datastore is and
no sequel database and to be more
specific it is a key value
column-oriented store it is key value
because the way you get them put
information is very similar to that of
hash tables or associative arrays in
programming languages and it's column
oriented which means that columns not
rows are stored together which means
better performance and scalability for
certain operations this also means that
datastore is not like a traditional
relational database system using sequel
the design of data store allows you to
create applications operating at Google
scale and by that we mean that your
application can scale in definitely
using distribution in the same way as
many of the very big Google services do
this means that your data is not only
stored on one computer or file system
but on multiple ones even in separate
data centers this type of distribution
increases performance as you can
retrieve data from these locations in
parallel your application does not need
to do anything extra to get all of this
value this is one of the great benefits
using data store you don't have to think
about it because datastore automatically
manages the scalability however this
also means that you need to design your
data model to take advantage of this and
when the data is stored in multiple
locations you also replicate the data
this means you can always rely on that
data being available because even if
there is a failure somewhere for example
a disk fails or a lightning struck sand
destroys a data center that data is
always available from another location
so with the design of data store you get
both scalability and availability
without having to do anything it's quite
amazing